we're gonna get it started with
eric who joins us in wilkes-barre
pennsylvania eric how can we help
hey how's it going we're having a blast
what's going on with you
not much um so so my situation is uh my
girlfriend and i have been together now
for about
11 years uh nine of which we have lived
together
and we also have a four-year-old son a
little bit before our son was born i
kind of took on the uh
the majority of everything that's
financial financially related such as
you know
expenses and and bills and such and um
it's been about almost a full year now
since i've been listening to dave ramsey
on the crew nonstop and it's got my uh
it's got me thinking about
uh marriage since i know you know what
he says about
keeping finances uh separated when
you're not actually married and such
and when i think about marriage i i feel
good about it it makes sense to
tie the knot you know both legally and
also also spiritually
however i also get uh these these
feelings of a little bit
of anger and resentment since i'm the
sole financial provider
right now uh so my question is do i do i
get married and accept my role as
uh what would be you know husband father
and and soul provider
since right now she said she wants to be
a stay at home mom
and if if i do um if if so
how do i move forward dealing with you
know any feeling
of resentment uh that tends to creep up
man you just you unpacked a lot here
um let's start with a couple of things
what are you still apprehensive about
after 11 years
a decade i don't know i guess i just got
used to um you know what we're doing um
i think
what would be what would be different
man what would be different if you're
married
that's the thing absolutely nothing
really whoa
except everything right except
everything yeah i guess though
wow and so the second thing is when you
talk about
um you're finally going to accept this
responsibility
that's nonsense brother you've already
accepted it you've got a kid that
responsibility is yours
you've committed to somebody for over a
decade that responsibility you've
already taken on
so it sounds like you've got some kind
of magical
unicorn barrier to this idea of quote
unquote marriage
the second thing is what are you getting
mad about dude what are you getting
frustrated about
yeah that's the thing and it was hard to
even admit that i felt
some sort of resentment even to myself
but i just noticed it creeping up every
now and then
what are you resenting um i guess you
know when
when our son was first born i thought
you know six months and she'll be back
to work and then a
a year later and a couple years later
and i guess really it's just
temporary brother brother
brother brother eric have you ever
stayed at home for an extended period of
time with a youngster
oh man a couple times yeah and i'm
waiting for her to get back
uh i'm gonna weigh in here wait wait
i've been i've been very patient
and i can no longer wait so eric okay
i'm gonna take a stab at something here
and i don't mind being wrong
it's happened before i think that the
source of the resentment
is that you aren't where you want to be
financially
you aren't where you want to be in your
life
and you feel like if she worked full
time
outside of the house she could help you
get where you want to be
and you're allowing your own
disappointment or your own
disillusionment with where you're at to
actually creep off of you
and over onto her i think that's what's
really going on
yes or no yeah i think i think that is a
big part of it here when you say that
um and and at the same time you know i
feel like in a rush to get
somewhere where i think i want to be
here's my concern
and i'm like john you pick up here i i
just
am concerned that if you don't get
healthy on your own problems with where
you are at
that getting married is going to be an
even bigger problem you resent her now
and you should not resent her
it's not a her problem it's a you
problem we're not beating up on you
but i would tell you right now no don't
get married until you get healthy
john eric i want to go back to something
you said a minute ago and just
stop myself for a second and i want to
applaud you
most men all right who find themselves
frustrated and angry
even if it's about things they know they
probably shouldn't be frustrated or
angry about
don't have the courage to say it out
loud so i want to high five you that is
true okay
good for you eric you're way ahead of
the curve
how old are you i'm 34.
you're 34. all right here's the deal i'm
going to say something that
pretty direct okay just because we're on
the radio we're on a clock
all right you've got to accept the fact
that you've got to grow
up okay okay
um one of the things that we do often is
we continually
think back to the way things were look
how cool it was when we were 18.
and look how cool it was when we first
met and we had freedom we were able to
run around look at the things we were
able to do when we had a dual income
look at the things we can't do now
because we have a kit and what happens
is you start dragging your old stuff
into the future trying to keep your
future
connected to your past brother you've
got a new world you have a child you
have a
stay-at-home mom who's trying to raise
that kid the best she can
you gotta love her brother i'm gonna
decide with kid you gotta take care of
you go see somebody and then you go get
married
eric stop asking am i where i want to be
and start
asking am i who i want to be get that
figured out
everything else will take care of